[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi again my name is brian wood i work in
pr here at wolfram research uh i'm
talking today with
daria parichna she's in the blockchain
group and she's been working on
new cryptography features in the wolfram
language
um so the main thing that it looks like
you're
you're talking about today has to do
with elliptic curve cryptography
uh could you explain just a little bit
about that concept and
and like what the importance is of
elliptic curve cryptography it sounds
sounds very complicated
hi brian and yes i
was going to talk about a lot of new
things that we have implemented
for the coming version of mathematica
12-2
and yes a big chunk of them as the
support of
more elliptic curves and elliptic curves
are an asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which means that
you gotta have two keys
one is your private key with which you
can decrypt
data or sign um
you know create digital signatures and a
public key that you're going to share
with others
for them to be able to verify your
digital signatures
and a big plus of the lippy keras
algorithm
is that they take much much less space
the actual keys and the signatures than
the rsa
and so they're faster to transmit and
they're easier to store
and that has gained them popularity
and the thing that has gained them
popularity was bitcoin
because yeah to start using them right
so
so this is something that's used pretty
commonly in in all kinds of blockchain
applications then
yeah i think most i mean i cannot come
up with a cryptocurrency that doesn't
use them
oh okay interesting um
so what exactly is it that's new uh
for for wolfram language in elliptic
cryptography right now
well mostly we have added support for
more olympic curves
the first time we rolled out the digital
on ellipticals uh we have just used the
one
that was used in bitcoin and mostly a
lot of cryptocurrencies
because we wanted to interact with those
blockchains
and since it worked well we have
perfected
you know the looks uh the way it's
represented and designed in the language
we're now just rolling more elliptic
curves to be
to keep up with the other libraries and
you know the curves that are recommended
by
institutions and the girls that are safe
and another thing was another
algorithm it's called the schnorr
digital signature
that's also based on liptickers it's
just slightly different
stylistic curve digital signature
um so now we're going to support three
different
digital signature algorithms which is
rsa
ecdsa which is the standard elliptic
curve
and schnorr
okay um so can you give me an example i
guess
uh i know you're talking about digital
signatures
um is is can you can you kind of
describe exactly
how people would use these algorithms
well a digital signature is sort of
like a normal paper signature you would
put on document
though it is much better because it's
binded to the actual information
inside the document so if something
changes
you may not be able to see it with your
eye you know if there is a type of there
is an extra zero in the zoom
you are agreeing to pay right okay
signature is gonna is gonna detect that
it's just not gonna verify anymore if
the file changes
so they're very important to establish
the authorship
and to be able to verify it
so it kind of you know put spouse binds
the person to a document
and then the information inside the
document
so it's almost like uh like checking a
signature on
on a check or a document or something
just
digitally just yeah yeah yeah well and
better obviously because like you said
computers do it a lot better
than we humans um
so what else is new
i know you you had a bit to talk about
with
file encryption i believe and uh
pem pem files so what can you tell me
about those
pm files as the format of storing and
transmitting
different cryptographic data including
keys
the certificates of encrypted data
signed data so it's kind of sort of a
standard
way one of the standard ways of storing
and transmitting
these cryptographic messages and a new
thing
and it's big new thing involved too is
we are able to
import those files and interact with
them
i mean i just gotta show it i cannot
just talk about it
sure yeah yeah absolutely so
um yeah here is the notebook that
specified that was
less than the new features that we have
at 12.2
and since we're now talking about pm
files
um you know it's a part of cryptography
but it's just
integrated fully into our import expert
framework and the language you just put
in a file
and it imports it in a way of the key
that is
already computable you just can take
this key and you know create digital
signatures with it
or uh encrypt something
and you know just to be clear the file
itself
is absolutely unreadable to to a normal
person
that's what it looked like oh yeah
and you know there are applications that
can read it
but to represent it in this way
completely computable
i don't think anyone else is doing it
and this is great
that's interesting so so it's the the
file itself is sort of in
in an encrypted structure but when we
import it it actually recognizes
this specific type and and cipher and
things like that is that how that works
yeah because that structure is encoded
according to some rules
um it has like tags it has the row bytes
uh and you gotta have to detangle it
basically and so we detangle it using
open ssl
and c plus plus and then that data
we also interpret involved from language
side to be able to give you this
cool so people can have any any number
of different
uh different methods for creating these
files and
when you import it it'll it'll sort of
automatically work
yeah for example if you already have
like your keys that are connecting you
to an
aws client you can connect
you can import them and you can use them
for example um and it's not just keys
this is also a new thing good wealth too
you know this file can have more things
than one uh it can have certificates and
you can see
all sorts of data who the certificate
was issued to
by whom when it's valid you could check
the validity
you could access all sorts of things
and that just often so yeah just opens a
lot of possibilities to interact with
those data yeah yeah so i can
i can imagine just a file with with
just pages and pages and pages of what
seems like
you know gibberish to any human uh and
then this
this well from language import can just
turn it into oh okay this is a
certificate this is a key this is you
know this
different uh different types of security
different encryption things
um yeah and you can just go and query
this
object for whatever thing you like
you know programmatically to be able to
compute or interact or ah that's cool
it's
more details so so what what other kinds
of properties can you get from those
uh in general
well you could just query for properties
sure
yeah that's the easy way okay yeah yeah
so yeah so not only does it recognize
all of these things
uh it can give you the individual pieces
of information
to sort of break it apart and be able to
process it in whatever way you want
i mean when we were where we were
developing and testing this i have
encountered the file that had 200
certificates in it
and we were just able to decode them too
wow that's that's pretty impressive yeah
that's that's
really interesting uh so i can imagine
that anybody who
who regularly deals with these kinds of
files would be really
interested to see this and it's also
useful
for again explaining what the things are
right yeah that makes sense
and on on the subject of explaining
things uh i know you've got a note
here about the course on wolfram use so
is that something that is going to be
coming up pretty soon
well i'm not sure about pretty soon but
it's something we've certainly started
to work on
um but now because we're preparing for
the release
it's sort of a little bit postponed to
groom all the certificates up
uh for the release so but this is going
to be coming
yes this is going to be a course on
introduction to cryptography
using all this you know amazing
functionality we already have an
apocalypse and in the language
in the unique way our language
can you know represent things
symbolically and computationally so you
can explain
all the sorts of uh you know
you can explain the algorithm of rsa
like here the skis
and this digital signatures as ever and
in our language you can explain this
just symbolically right in the equation
however essay works
and the same time was this practical
things
right so uh so who exactly planned to be
like about 30 lectures
15 minutes each maybe more so
that's still going to be pretty profound
and and that's is that targeted for
um like undergrads you said in in
cryptography
or what types of foods targeted for
like undergrad students uh they're
studying computer science
and you know wanna familiarize
themselves
with cryptography because you know in
the modern world
it's everywhere like you just gotta know
it
you gotta know how to use it and what it
does and what is the difference between
hash encryption and digital signature
yeah and i can i can definitely uh
imagine
this would have been a really
interesting course for me in my
undergrad so
um because i have done lectures for the
summer school
already and i have studied cryptography
in my university
i have notes i have the books i have the
support of stephen who is very
proficient in writing books and courses
so i think we're going to pull it off
perfectly
excellent uh well was there anything
else you wanted to
show off from your notebook real quick
before we wrap up here
well i wanted to show the the actual
list of curse that we are going to be
supporting
um the things that we have talked before
um so yeah initially there was only this
curve
that is the one that bitcoin and
ethereum and other things are based on
but now he we have added five more and
before the release there may be more
if i have time um and
you can just specify now any curve to
generate
keys and you can generate
digital signatures and it will
automatically take the same curve
you don't have to specify it anymore and
it just all works together
so so just out of out of sheer curiosity
because
the um the one of these 256
ones was was used in uh ethereum and
bitcoin and
um so do we actually have are there
actually
algorithms here that are more secure
than what's used in
uh bitcoin ethereum and other blockchain
applications the numbers here
stand for the length of the key
and for the things the length of the key
is one of the good metrics because
in the worst case you just have to brute
force all the keys
so the longer the key the better so you
know see this one has the key
twice as long yeah yeah i saw that
number and i thought that might be the
case
yeah that's it's very easy just to
provide
more security but
i mean even this is enough
right right yeah for the time being of
humanity this is now
enough yeah until until we get uh
quantum quantum decryption then uh
in theory these should all be more than
enough for most purposes
nest is already working on the
cryptographic standard
for the ciphers and signatures that are
going to be resistant to quantum
computers so
it might actually come out even before
quantum computers themselves
oh well there you go um interesting yeah
good to know
um cool well thank you very much
uh this is all really excellent
information and i am
looking forward to uh i will probably
take your
your blockchain uh course whenever it is
available
so thanks a lot now this is going to be
to be cryptography course
oh cryptography it's going to be also a
blockchain course that are other
i get the blockchain buzzword stuck in
my head so the two are almost the same
to me but you're right yeah cryptography
is even its own interesting subject
aside from its applications to
blockchain so
either either course i would be very
interested to take and thank you very
much
for for talking with me today thank you
bye thanks for joining us
you can check out other wolfram tech
talks live coding streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com